[Music]
Jupiter maybe the biggest planet in the
solar system but its days are numbered
because today we're using Earth's
biggest baddest bombs to blow the gas
giant into Oblivion
how many nukes would you need to do the
job
what obstacles would these rocket-bound
bombs encounter on the way
and would one nuclear explosion ignite
the entire planet
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked Jupiter
nuclear weapons are so powerful that
even the low-yield versions like those
dropped on Japan by the United States in
World War II have the explosive
equivalent of 15 to 20 kilotons of
dynamite each
what makes them so volatile is that they
harness the intense energy releasing
power of nuclear fission or Fusion
these are the same processes that happen
in our very own Sun
so be careful when moving these things
out to Jupiter
one false move and you could be
incinerated by a fireball as hot as the
center of the Sun
in order to blow Jupiter to bits one
single bomb wouldn't necessarily be up
for the task
good thing for this scenario that there
are a lot of nuclear weapons on Earth
maybe the safest plan would be getting
them all off our planet anyway
given the top secret nature of military
activities it's hard to know the exact
number but estimates put the global
Arsenal at about 12 700 with the United
States and Russia battling for top spot
with 5500 to 6 000 weapons each
okay there's no use in delaying let's
get these rockets off Earth as fast as
possible
distance between Earth and Jupiter
fluctuates from about 590 million to 970
million kilometers
in the past missions like the Galileo
space probe took nearly five years to
make the journey to the gas giant
but our Rockets wouldn't take this long
Galileo had to be slow enough to enter
Jupiter's orbit we just need to hit the
planet head on so you'd only be looking
at about 550 to 650 days to get the job
done
you shouldn't be too Reckless and Speedy
though you don't want to Nuke something
else by accident
now bypassing the moon and Mars would be
easy enough but getting safely through
the asteroid belt would be like
navigating a minefield
there are millions of asteroids riddled
between Mars and Jupiter and while the
average distance between them is a not
so worrisome 966 000 kilometers
sometimes it can still get a little
cramped in there and Jupiter is partly
to blame for this
planet's massive gravitational influence
causes many of these to group into
clusters known as families carelessly
navigate through one like the Flora
family and you'd better hope none of our
Rockets would collide with any of its
400 asteroids
for the best chance of success you
should aim to transport your Rockets
through the Kirkwood gaps these are
nearly asteroid-free regions in the belt
because you'd hate to see all of our
planet's nukes detonate themselves in a
blinding Chain Reaction before reaching
our Target
as the first of our bombs exploded on
Jupiter you'd see bright flashes back
here on Earth
just like when the Shoemaker Levy 9
Comet slammed into Jupiter in 1994.
but that only released five percent as
much energy as the Tsar Bomba the
largest bomb ever created
so with thousands of our nuclear bombs
Jupiter's days would have to be numbered
right
well not exactly even though our nukes
could produce an explosion hotter than
the sun this wouldn't cause all the
hydrogen on Jupiter to ignite it just
isn't dense enough to sustain nuclear
fusion
and even if every bomb was detonated
Jupiter wouldn't blow up completely
either
in order to do that we'd need to unleash
as much energy as the sun releases over
160 years all at once and for that
highly energetic result about 1 billion
billion nukes would be required
somewhat more than the 12 700 in our
Arsenal
to build that many bombs you'd need a
combined mass of material that would
almost be twice that of the largest moon
in the solar system
Jupiter's Ganymede
no small feat since it's bigger than
Pluto and Mercury
all right well that was pretty
anti-climactic maybe you'd be better off
seeing what could happen by taking
things to the extreme here on Earth
like dropping a nuke into the deepest
part of the ocean
but that's a story or another